good to see you snoop always a pleasure  you know snoop I like to be honest with  people we had a little bit of trouble  and because unlike most of our other  guests who stay within feet of the stage  right we had some problems in the past  when you and I'm gonna say entourage a  group of friends show up we've had some  problems so with ventilation in the  building so we actually in preparation  for your coming set up your own trailer  which is really far right but you're  comfortable having your own trail oven  at the fire alarms don't work I mean  everything we've done this and this is  true we've done this for only two people  in the history of the show you and  Willie Nelson  [Applause]  you